what is going on everybody and welcome
to a video on github co-pilot so there's
been a lot of hype and uh dangers
expressed with co-pilot and it's been
hard for me because i haven't had access
until a few weeks ago so i finally have
had some time to play around with
co-pilot and i thought i would share my
thoughts with you all so if you're been
living under a rock and you don't know
what co-pilot is it's just an in-editor
extension that makes suggestions to you
as you code basically it tries to finish
your lines or even suggest entire blocks
of code so it's an interesting concept
and obviously this spawns all kinds of
issues especially because it was trained
off of github data
and so there's like privacy concerns
security concerns and then people are
worried that their jobs are going to be
taken away so so first off how does it
work uh does it work well and then what
about all these other little
issues with something like this first
off copilot was created using openai's
codex model which is a variant of gpd3
but codex defers in three what i would
call major ways to illustrate things
here we're actually going to use copilot
so first off it's smaller gpt 3 is 175
billion parameters whereas codex is 12
billion parameters
this smaller model makes it a bit
quicker to run or at least easier to run
quickly as well as makes it easier to
scale out and here you can see just how
quickly we made a bar chart with copilot
to compare these two sizes each time
that you see this great text that's the
suggestion from copilot and i just hit
tab to accept them interestingly it even
gave it a title and labels the y label
is not quite accurate we would want to
change that but it would be very easy
for us to just edit that in and still be
way quicker than if i tried to code this
all by hand myself
so gpt 3 is indeed far larger and can
arguably do a lot more but it also has a
knowledge base of basically everything
gbd3 is general purpose it includes
concepts of coding but also law medicine
conversation and a whole lot more codex
is only concerned with coding so it's
much smaller piece of the total pi and a
much smaller model can actually be
better at coding than full scale gpt3
there are also a lot of really little
subtle things that you wouldn't expect
copilot to do but it does so in case you
missed it as we adjust to these
percentages the suggested percentage
that comes next is mathematically
accurate
as a subtraction from a total of one
hundred percent so not only does it have
to understand that you would max out at
a hundred percent it's doing the math
which is really cool
the final way that codex differs from
gpt-3 is codecs and copilot have a giant
context length of understanding
essentially it's a question of how large
can your file be before a codex can't
ingest everything in your file so some
of the earlier and further away code
might be ignored when generating
suggestions the context size of gpt 3 is
4 kilobytes whereas the context size of
codecs or github's copilot is 14
kilobytes so then the next question you
probably have is okay well how much code
is 14 kilobytes well i've got a
directory with a bunch of python files
from github repositories so let's just
see if we can find one that's about 14
kilobytes and using github copilot we
did find a file and we see that 14
kilobytes is about 400 lines or so which
is considerably large obviously
sometimes your files will be bigger and
it's not like copilot just won't work
it's just that it won't be able to take
your entire file into context next let's
cover an example of some regular
expressions so say we've got a sentence
and we want the regular expression to
find the price of something in there
we'll let copilot write a regular
expression as well as print it out for
us
but before we run this let me show you
something really cool what if we write a
comment that begins to say what the
output will be or should be
but we let copilot finish the comment
it turns out that copilot knows exactly
what the output will be here
this is my own made up example it exists
nowhere certainly not in the data set it
was trained on
this is an example of transformers in
their understanding that i've used in
the past but usually transformers aren't
too accurate here i can only sometimes
get it to get this right
copilot gets this right
every time i couldn't trip it up
i'm sure it's possible to trip it up but
asking copilot to tell me the expected
output at least for me has just plain
worked
and this signals a deeper understanding
than just simply pattern matching
notice too that it gets the format right
it's going to come in the form of a list
we can change our requested regex to
include the dollar sign too and again we
can ask copilot to tell us what's the
output going to be now
it's correct
what if we add another dollar amount
here again the same thing copilot not
only wrote our regex it actually knows
what the output of the regex will be
now we could keep going here and this
doesn't necessarily have any super
important direct use to us
but i hope it drives home that there's
more going on here than just simply
pattern matching and sort of
regurgitating things it's seen before
there's a deeper understanding this
doesn't necessarily have any direct use
to us but
it's really
cool let's do something even more absurd
i'm going to import a non-existent
package called sentiment analysis
i'll create an example sentence and we
can keep the suggested string too for
now later we'll try something else
next i will pretend this made up module
again
has a made up method
i'm literally just making all of this up
right now
anyway we're going to say that method is
called analyze now rather than running
let's just do the same thing let copilot
predict the output
and yeah
that's insane
okay so let's go ahead and try our own
sentence next not one that copilot came
up with for us
this time negative 1.0 that makes sense
much of the time i think you're going to
get return something between a negative
one and a positive one
but you might also get a string positive
or a string of negative something like
that
trying a few more examples you can see
it gets it right every single time
and again
there is no sentiment analysis module
here there might be a module called
sentiment analysis but what's important
is it doesn't exist and i don't think it
has an analyze method
but
it's just co-pilot this is so crazy and
i really want to stress these were all
unplanned examples i just tried them and
they worked same thing with the regular
expressions examples i'm really not
cherry picking here even though the
performance looks like i'm cherry
picking
copilot is simply that good and it
really is staggering to me and if you
have co-pilot i really encourage you to
try like more
um kind of out there examples like this
because it's it's actually really
surprising what copilot can
uh can actually do
so now for some of the problems people
have brought up the first one being it's
going to steal our jobs
and i i don't think that's true i i
think eventually you might have an ai
that a normal person could dictate their
wants and needs to and the ai could
plausibly code that but at the end of
the day
it's just like programming languages are
just that they're languages it's our way
of explaining to a machine what we want
so i'm not really sure
that having an ai that you can explain
what you want
and it produces it is that far off of
programming the leap the difference of
using something like copilot it's almost
like an extra layer of abstraction not
all that different from
using python over using something like c
plus plus
and
a perfect example of this and what i
would argue is a productivity boost
which is python i think the same thing
is going to be true with stuff like
github co-pilot where
you're
able to be far more productive and when
you're more productive
there's more of a reason for someone to
hire you so it's not really the case
that we'll have less job openings if
anything it would be more job openings
even if you do remedial stuff as a
programmer this will make you more
productive
more valuable so i'm not i'm just not
sure i'm buying that it's going to steal
anybody's jobs but you also kind of need
to have some sort of contextual
understanding at least under the current
version of copilot again it's it's
totally possible in the future
that you won't and it anyone could just
dictate to something like copilot hey
make xyz for me but i think you're still
going to need people that will still
architect overarching things
it's possible that an ai could do that
but i at least to me i see this as
really more of a layer of abstraction
and a productivity boost
which
most likely would just create more jobs
more people could afford to hire you
because you're far more productive so i
don't know i that's at least the way
that i see it i know people will
disagree uh with with that take but
that's that's kind of how i'm seeing it
also i've seen at least for me
personally like copilot has taught me
things i've thought about libraries that
i haven't had the chance to really look
into using and i just kind of started
writing code and said hey i want to do
this thing with that library and it just
kind of guided me along the way to teach
me how to use that library and i found
that to be really really cool there were
also times where i wanted to see if
co-pilot could do something that i was
familiar with and then it ended up doing
it in a different way that i had never
really thought about or even using a
method that i didn't even know existed
so it's taught me stuff and i also think
that's that's really cool
so i also think that copilot does make
mistakes right it's got logical errors
that it makes it makes
errors in what it thinks you're going
after but you're not really there's a
skill involved in how to prompt
a copilot to give you what you want
so not all that unlike using a search
engine for example so
um i think that overall i was personally
very very impressed with with what
copilot could do for me uh i kind of
came into this expecting to not like it
i tend to like very simple editors i
don't like auto complete stuff um so for
me i was almost biased to
not like co-pilot but i i i really enjoy
it i think it's it's a really cool
innovation um both in terms of how
they've applied a transformer model and
built it into an editor how fast it is
is a 12 billion parameter model and it
inferences
very quickly
especially given the context size so
um
yeah i think it's a really well
integrated thing and the technology and
the actual accuracy of what it's
actually producing i find it to be far
more useful than not like i said it does
sometimes produce silly things but for
the most part it is very helpful very
quick and again i tend to find it most
useful in the more remedial task type
stuff that i need to do while i'm
programming and again i think that's
great it just all it's done is make me
more productive so anyway
at least for now i really do like it
i hope that the future is not dystopic
and that we aren't all replaced by
something like copilot but that's not
really how i see it going in closing
i'll share a particularly cool example
that i stumbled on by just simply poking
around with github co-pilot and it is
conway's game of life and then
visualizing it with pygame this
particular example worked on the first
try and this is the order that i went
through to actually produce it but i
have tried other larger projects and
more complicated stuff like this to be
done completely by copilot and it it
really didn't work so of everything i've
shown here this is the most cherry
picked example but uh still really cool
to see
anyway that's all for now i honestly
can't wait to see what the future holds
with this kind of technology let me know
what you think down below and with that
i'll see you all in another video
you